[Música]
la moda es un canal de difusión
es un mundo de intercambio
permite comunicar compartir valores
tradicionales nacionales e
internacionales permite descubrir
[Música]
al principio diré que mi padre no lo
hace todas excepto
pero mi madre siempre me ha apoyado y se
lo agradezco
además ella fue un gran apoyo para mí y
hoy gracias al fruto de mi trabajo a lo
que he hecho mi padre también me apoya y
es pernicioso de mí
todos están orgullosos de mí se lo
agradezco
así se expresa a la arista sol y mame
led de 26 años musa de la novena edición
décimo 228 el festival internacional de
la moda de todo para entender los
valores de este festival qué mejor
manera de empezar que dando la palabra a
sus embajadores
las modelos mientras desfilan en la
pasarela también tienen otras vidas que
revelan los profundos cambios que se
están produciendo en las sociedades
africanas
además de modelar conduzco vehículos
pesados concretamente grúas y carros
porque no me gustan mucho las cosas de
mujeres aparte del modelaje modelar es
un sueño no se podría decir que me gusta
mucho conducir una grúa es una pasión al
principio no fue fácil porque era la
única mujer entre muchos hombres
entonces me dijeron que no podían que
era cosa de hombres que no tenía la
fuerza que debía dedicarme a la belleza
oa la peluquería pensé no una mujer
también puede hacer lo que hace un
hombre
así que invito a todo el mundo a hacer
lo mismo que yo y demostraremos de lo
que somos capaces las mujeres
katy cruz y cumplió 20 años hace poco no
tiene el típico perfil de modelo de
hecho no lo es
dirige documentales para la televisión
togolesa new world tv lo método es una
prueba es realmente un reto físico
porque hay varios días de preparación y
luego antes de eso hay horas de
entrenamiento así un famoso presidente
había dicho no marcha todo el que quiere
sino todo el que puede así que si
efectivamente fue mucho trabajo y bueno
fue un gran momento de felicidad por lo
menos lo hice una vez en mi vida
se elimine en cambio lleva una buena
década haciendo esto y nunca se cansa de
hacerlo es el momento en que me digo no
queda nadie es mi mundo si es
extraordinario no sé cómo expresar lo es
algo que hay que sentir que sucede lo
mismo con los actores o los constantes
cuando cogen el micrófono para analizar
se sienten bien están a gusto en su
mundo es la sensación que tengo las
pasarelas es un gran escenario como el
de fimo con hermosos trajes con gran
música simplemente se me pone la piel de
gallina eso es bola y saco eso se llama
tener amor por lo que haces de fósforo
hadas u también conocido como álex cep
fue nominado en los premios de la moda
de todo el 2021 en la categoría modelo
masculino del año alex es andrógino en
su familia la aceptación ha sido gradual
pero en la calle la situación es
diferente sigue siendo objeto de
frecuentes burlas oye tú eres hombre o
mujer
y nada ha cambiado salvo que la gente
empieza a reconocerme
y ahora aparezco en algunos vídeos para
filmar un poco lo que hago así que si
está bien
así que se trata de afirmar que tu
persona
de eso se trata
en una palabra de quién eres
bueno en una palabra ya mi nombre es
amor así que soy alguien de amor
esa dulzura
esta mujer esa luz del tiempo y la
persona que controla todo
esta temporada alex cep se ha convertido
en una musa su look inspiró a la
diseñadora etíope orden de afro tian
etiopía el lado andrógino tampoco
frecuente en áfrica que no se resalta
tanto me llamó tanto la atención que
creé un traje de tres piezas para alias
es un chaleco de hecho en etiopía bueno
es de ning etíope perdón con pantalones
en realidad se parece un poco a un traje
de hombre con este detalle en el lateral
los botones de una leona porque vengo de
etiopía el símbolo es el león la
chaqueta femenina y masculina a la vez
también está confeccionada con deming el
cuello es de cuero etíope detrás tienes
un tejido senegalés y cuando se lo puso
le dije pero cómo te sientes ahí dentro
y me siento como un príncipe
álex se ha encendido el espíritu
creativo de ustedes being the a porque
ambos reclaman y defienden una libertad
de pensamiento una apertura mental sin
límites que se extendería a un
continente africano sin fronteras
principio que subyace en todas las
colecciones afrodescendientes el lema de
mi marca de hecho the square áfrica
crowd es de áfrica al resto del mundo se
dirige a todos los que aman a áfrica y
es para mostrar que se puede consumir
productos africanos y consumir cosas que
son y vueltas que tenemos mucha
excelencia aplicante por eso solo
trabajo con artesanos hay una calidad
hay una excelencia detrás tenemos muchas
cosas que ofrecer y consumismo al
presentar una diversidad de edades
cuerpos y andares esta novena edición
decimos 228 brilla por su compromiso de
mover las líneas y sentar las bases de
lo que podría llegar a ser un sueño
africano para áfrica